all right let's bring out Josie now an
activist for Emily's lists comedian and
host of eponymously titled talk show on
Netflix now streaming episodes for its
second season one of our favorites
Chelsea Handler
ready for you
[Music]
okay
how are you I'm good I'm gonna work some
positive energy and we're gonna get
excited about what happened in Virginia
what happened in New Jersey we had a lot
of good news we had a lot of women
elected true so we have to focus on that
as you said earlier it's the resistance
but there were women who out of the 16
women that emily's list sponsored 13:1
and got elected in the Virginia House of
Delegates our first african-americans
elected we had our first Latinas elected
in that state we had our first
transgender person we had our first
Asian American woman elected to the
Virginia House of Delegates so it
delicates it's it is it is an important
time and there are things to recognize
that are happening the world is getting
browner and gayer and everybody needs to
hop on
you know I mean it is a devastating
circumstance that we're in but there are
good things happening so we have to kind
of hold on to that hope I think my first
question
well I was gonna ask you what's going on
with you though before we get to all
that [ __ ] take it anymore we care
about you you're not doing your show
anymore you're more of an activist now I
have to be I feel like you know what I
have money I don't have to work I can
spend my time trying to get women
elected we need women in office we do
and I think Elizabeth Warren really has
to run for president that's the woman
especially at this moment
emily's let's recruit it they took her
and said you should run for office yes I
mean this is a great organization for
anybody who wants to support women to
support so 19 percent of the house is
only 19 percent of our women and 21
percent of the Senate but women vote why
don't they vote through themselves well
I think that we had I mean this is my
personal opinion and I think this is I
think we had a thing where women have a
truck problem supporting other women and
powerful you know situations they don't
have a problem electing a predator but
they have a problem electing somebody
who stayed with a predator you know what
I mean like with Hillary it was like
well we can't even liked her
because she's with but they don't have a
problem electing the man so it's almost
like there's a backlash on women that
don't support women and now that we have
this maniac in office I think women are
like oh [ __ ] ski
oh this is not what we planned on I
think the backlash that we're seeing now
with the sexual harassment and
everything is is the reaction to Trump
being the president of our country but
he's still one white women right now I
mean and that was after the Hollywood
access tape do you think the child is
child molester with Roy Moore different
I feel like that is a litmus test
talking about truth that is a litmus
test for whether Fox News in that crowd
can make something just not because Roy
Moore's attitude about everything is
well she's lying or that that yearbook
is a forgery
or it's fake news he's got Zillah
blaming Tokyo Brook he's literally
saying oh well Tokyo was asking for what
do you expect
but there's a big difference between
somebody taking accountability and
responsibility for for an act and and
somebody giving blanket denials and then
accusing their accusers of lying and
then you know pretending they're gonna
sue them on what grounds I don't know
because I'm you know when there are more
than one person that comes forward then
you take that seriously I agree with you
on Al Franken I'm sorry he's not a
predator we all know anybody who's met
him knows that's not true and also I
feel like we've lost our ability to
think in this country to tell unlike
things arts yeah I mean there's a
there's a difference between zero
tolerance we have zero tolerance of that
and maximum punishment does everything
have to be met I mean we don't have that
for murder there are different grades of
murder and other crimes not for this I
think that the focus on the punishment
and on what the repercussion is gonna be
is where this conversation goes wrong
and I think is largely steered by a
media that immediately after a picture
is published says do you think he should
resign like within three hours somebody
has to somebody has to write the media
sets up the conversation it is not the
women telling the stories who are coming
for these guys jobs directly in fact
many of them are going I don't know I
feel wait I don't know what it means but
but the the focus on the what the
punishment is going to be is also on
some level an easier conversation to
have because then we get to fight about
it should he resign and we all go to our
partisan battle stations then actually
looking at the more difficult
conversation which is that it is about
the whole culture it's about the culture
that empowers white men to abuse their
power in a million ways from the
villainous predators to the fact that
there is a sense of humor that we all
understand in this country that if a
woman's asleep it's funny to grab her
tits and that a man can gain power and
stature in a place in the public sphere
by profiting from that from that comedy
that doesn't make him the same as Harvey
Weinstein and it's not about him it's
about reckoning with the fact that we
make that culture we participate in that
culture it's our good politicians it's
our friends it's our husbands
and it's ourselves that is a harder
conversation to have and it's the one we
should be having about this moment not
should he resign and will a governor
appoint right but I think that is a
conversation we are having I think we're
deciding like okay now it's becoming too
you know there's a tipping point
happening this is happening everywhere
what are we gonna do about it what are
the repercussions going to sex rehab in
Arizona at the meadows is that gonna fix
Harvey right right right now I mean
they're a larger problem that we have of
not being able in this culture to look
at things contextually - yes I think to
make distinctions in our politics in in
our views of gender in all kinds of
questions the inability to to recognize
context as the all-important aspect of
the truth facts strung together
individually are not necessarily the
truth and that's the Internet is
everything it goes to media it goes to
the questions that we're discussing here
and it also means in the case of Trump
there is a possibility that after this
special prosecutor if he's permitted to
finish his investigation it's possible
he won't find a conspiracy but yet there
will be one would hope a report that
puts everything into context that's what
we lack on a daily basis in our culture
can I ask just about the politics though
because I take your point and I think
it's valid but it is caught kind of
important who is in the Senate right now
I mean that's why they're willing to put
up with maybe a child molester to get
the vote for the tax cuts that's how
they played the game I'm not suggesting
we go there or that far but how Franken
can't be in the Senate we don't need his
vote because we do we do need his vote
on things that affect millions and
millions of people so we can do two
things at once we can have this okay of
course we can my complaint is with the
fact that it immediately goes to the
question it's you know people just wrote
that or said that they just people on
the line TV and they say to trampo will
he fire Bob Muller it's like don't say
that don't give him any [ __ ] ideas
it occurred to him first but I don't
think you needed to put that said I
heard from people who are making this
argument yesterday was well we have to
get rid of Al Franken because otherwise
it's a push they're gonna say Al Franken
we say Roy Moore and this is what
Democrats always do they shrink from
making the counter argument instead of
going there with a well we can't win
this we're just going to go away
let him resign make the counter right do
what I just did in the monologue say
he's not the Zodiac killer it's not the
same thing
[Music]
and Democrats should be able to point
out that Al Franken's reaction is to
begin an investigation into his behavior
and that given that not to not to give
him cookies that's correct that's a good
response we should also have an
investigation into the 16 women who have
accused Donald Trump listen this is what
I was saying earlier was the reaction to
women voting for Donald Trump they act
the reaction of women voting for
somebody who admitted on tape that he's
a sexual predator he admitted it was
bragging about it they went and voted
for him and that that after effect I
think you know that pendulum of looking
at what they've done I think has led to
this I believe that I think women are
sick and tired of being sick and tired
not to go out fannie lou hamer in the
civil rights movement but women are just
like no my god look what we did and
better late than ever you know I want
women who stick up for each other and
look out for each other and never
facilitate any Harvey Weinstein [ __ ]
like this again but this has to be this
this has to be a long day that we have
to play a cultural long game because we
don't want to find ourselves in the
exact same trap we found ourselves after
Obama because right after Obama got
elected suddenly everybody was spouting
that we were living in a post-racial
Society years to get here right we can't
say suddenly we're living in a post
sexist society because remember while
all this is happening right now we're
talking about this great backlash people
are speaking up the number two movie in
the country is starring Mel Gibson all
right so let's not pretend this is going
to go away overnight this has to start
with our kids what we teach them how we
teach little girls to fight back how we
teach little boys to respect girls this
has to be a long cultural game that we
play for the next generation okay can I
bring up one other aspect of this
before you say anything I just want to
go on the record and say that I'm
currently dating Mel Gibson so that was
[ __ ] up that you just did that I mean
I forgive you daddy's home - forgives
you - oh really I almost was gonna ask
you how's it going who knows I like
older man not that old
no offense Carl it's okay
[Applause]